alors si nous proposons des livres à la
bibliothèque si les gens s'attendent à
avoir des livres à la bibliothèque
bien vu évidemment nous proposons des
livres mais grâce au dépôt légal nous
pouvons proposer une multitude de
supports imprimés des collections
originales uniques à la réunion et qu'on
va pas trouver dans le commerce
parce qu'ils sont pas soit diffusée
confidentiellement soit
pour le cas des affiches justement un
prix mais uniquement pour une campagne
une campagne bien précises dans un temps
limité donc grâce au dépôt légal nous
recueillons tout le patrimoine imprimés
de la réunion et que ce soit donc des
affiches des tracts des dépliants et des
journaux des mets tous les journaux tous
types de journaux des journaux qui sont
à la fois dans les kiosques et qui sont
connus de tous les réunionnais des
journaux des titres qui sont connues de
quelques-uns puisqu'ils sont diffusées
on peut en comité restreint soit au sein
d'une entreprise soit au sein d'une
association soit dans un seul quartier
donc vraiment eu le dépôt légal nous
permet de proposer des collections très
original quasiment unique à la réunion
et paul égal nous permet d'avoir un
panel de documents très très très large
alors la particularité à la réunion sais
c'est que dépôt légal nous nous sommes
habilités à gérer le dépôt si bien le
dépôt légal éditeurs et le dépôt légal
imprimés en france seule la ville de
technos ionale j'ai le dépôt légal
éditeurs mais à la réunion particularité
de myennes la réunion va va connecter le
dépôt légal éditeurs en plus du dépôt
légal imprimeurs
et donc à charge pour la bibliothèque
départementale donc de conserver ces
documents
une partie est conservé une partie du
dépôt légal éditeur est envoyé sur une
dette nationale de france
et une autre partie et communiqué donc
c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas toujours
le nombre d'exemplaires suffisant pour
pouvoir communiquer donc à ce moment là
heureusement
grâce
à des crédits donc nous pouvons acheter
en complément de ce qu'il déposait au
dépôt légal et il est proposé la
communication
moi